just recently somebody who was actually
writing a book about Francis Bacon and
following around with a tape recorder
had recorded a conversation drunken
conversation between bacon and doll in
which both of them talks about what you
know posterity and whether anyone should
change their work after they would
apparently it's incredibly emphatic that
he thought you know essentially
political correctness as it would then
have been called
um was going to be you know utterly
destructive to his work and if anyone
changed it after his death
um he would send The Enormous Crocodile
to go and eat them
um I mean the only important to make
about this maybe is that you know tough
luck rolled um